more than 200,000 people in Florida this
morning are staying in shelters for
protection against hurricane Irma Jeff
Glor visited with some of them he's in
st. Pete Beach that's near Tampa Bay
Jeff good morning again good morning
again to you Pinellas County outside
Tampa took in around 17,000 people in
2000 pets
we got a first-hand look at a shelter in
st. Petersburg that right now is helping
people with their temporary new reality
the classrooms in hallways of John
Hopkins middle school are lined with
more than 1,200 people waiting for irma
to pass your name is what your name is
Irma I've been in many tornadoes but not
hurricane most of the people here have
special needs some are elderly and some
needed a safe place to stay with their
pets we have a little Monteith sit
through a little dog and we wanted him
to come with us
Donnell Rogers and his 9 year old
daughter Brianna say had to move out of
the gym because of concerns about the
roof but she remains positive what's it
been like here spending time with all
these folks good because most of these
people are really nice and a bit helping
one another so yes it's actually very
happy being here their dog joined over
300 other pets at this st. Petersburg
shelter this is rocky joseph sato my
service dog well Gina Seidel and rocky
are in a safe location now the aftermath
of the storm remains undermind scariest
part for me with the storm is how many
people could go home and have no place
to live so that's scary 89 year old Emma
who we met and that is her real name she
showed us her license was one of the
most memorable people we've met down
here she lives alone in a small wooden
house that's why she went to the shelter
but she is safe now and she's looking
forward to get back home and keep in
mind
Nora a lot of the folks who are helping
those in these shelters are volunteers
it's really good right Jeff Glor
checking licenses at the shelter we're
glad that herb oh okay I believe you I
believe you but just goes didn't why
Florida is so great yeah they say one in
five is on your citizens but a lot of
really strong people there and trying to
stay safe so thank you Jeff